two explorers recently made history by
crossing Antarctica alone without anyone
to help the trek has been attempted
before but was never completed in
November American adventure athlete
Colin O'Grady and British Army officer
captain Lou Rudd each started the
daunting journey separately more than
900 miles they skied across the world's
coldest and driest continent without a
single day of rest a solo trek across
the Antarctic was thought to be
impossible but on November 3rd two men
set out to make history 49 year-old
British Army captain Lou Rudd and 33
year old American Colin O'Brady a plane
dropped them about a mile apart on the
ice shelf the goal was to make the more
than 900 mile trek alone across
Antarctica using just cross-country skis
while pulling a heavy sled of supplies
they bad wind and then steep snow they
battled against elements like wind gusts
up to 60 miles per hour freezing
temperatures that dipped below negative
40 degrees and whiteout conditions
conditions they had trained for during
the months prior previous attempts
across Antarctica were not successful
British explorer Henry world's lead IED
shortly after trying to complete the
trek in 2016 on the final leg of his
journey Oh Brady skied the roughly 80
remaining miles in just over 32 hours he
finished in 54 days on December 26th
when Rudd crossed the finish line just
two days later Oh Brady was there to
celebrate the incredible feat they had
accomplished
Lou red is also the only person to have
cross Antarctica twice once with a group
and once solo he joins us only on CBS
this morning welcome congratulations so
this all took place right before your
50th birthday what a way to celebrate
that milestone what did it feel like
when you finally made it yeah I mean
absolutely elated you know I was really
conscious when I set off on the
expedition that nobody had managed to do
this before so
you know success was by no means
guaranteed and to finally make it after
56 days you know on to the Ross Ice
Shelf at the finish point was just an
amazing feeling and huge relief that I
didn't manage to do it yet no means
guaranteed I mean somebody already
passed away trying to attempt just that
20 days into the truck you made a
mistake that put you in danger why
didn't you end it there yeah so I've
gotten to know really deep soft snow it
was a very difficult season this year
down in Antarctica with him out snowfall
and soft snow and one morning had been
snowing all night I got up and I could
barely move the pole cleaner which
weighed about 130 kilograms what [ __ ]
it's a sledge just let yeah that's what
you're dragging behind you've got you
know it's based your life pot it's got
everything in there you need to survive
for the two months all my food and tents
and equipment yeah I could barely move
it because of the deep soft snow so I
took half of the stuff out my tents and
sleeping bag and sort of put it on the
surface and marked it with a ski and
then I went forward a few miles with
that with all the food drop that off and
in the meantime the weather really
deteriorated and visibility went down to
about 5 meters 50 mile an hour wind and
I was trying to follow it back along
with ski tracks to recover my tent and
sleeping bag and it was quite difficult
to manage to locate it in the end but it
took me a while and I was conscious that
if I didn't find that gear that
instantly I was in a life-threatening
situation there had to be an honest
question they'll finish that she said
why didn't you end it then there were
many times I bet you thought I can't
make it I can do it yeah I mean oh you
know really keen obviously we talked
about Henri words Lee you know suddenly
the Briton had died three years ago
Templars journey so Henry was a friend
of mine my ski to the South Pole with
Henry in 2011 and shared a temp with him
so you know it was really keen that I
was you know sort of was safe and
successful
I was I was fundraising for some great
charities great causes and then just the
amount of support and people and unit
were backing me I just didn't want to
let everyone down there's a lesson for
so many of us to learn from you because
you said every time you felt like
stopping you did what yes I 11 steps
yeah so I heard me a years ago something
somebody told me you know that somebody
calc aids with captain Scott you know
obviously when you reached the South
Pole on the way back they were trying to
reach a Depot of food
and equipments you know and had they
reached that they would have survived
somebody had calculated the the the
Scott team every day they've taken an
extra 11 steps they probably would have
you know made it back to one ton depot
and survived the journey and after
hearing that and whenever I'm on a polar
journey now I'll sort of finish skiing
for the day and you know and whether it
be eight o'clock and then I'll always
take any steps extra steps it's like a
superstition now once I started doing I
can't stop doing I have to like Bruce
Springsteen yes gotten through and Bono
listening to their music songs you were
listening to and what books you said
just listening to another voice was
helpful yes obviously being on my own
you know
it was a true song what was it bono song
you know say born in the USA actually
was really sort of perk me up you know
Bono's you know I I think it's so
mysterious you know and you were reading
listening and books on tape yeah so I
had a lot of audiobooks which I found
really comforting to have like you know
sort of human voice nomad was talking to
me as a skiing along because it wouldn't
be howling and it was quite lonely so
what kind of books though Winston
Churchill fight on the beaches you know
yeah that was just reciting a lot of
sort Churchill's famous speeches has
really sort of motivational stuff he ate
six thousand calories a day burning ten
thousand carrying about ten thousand
yeah dropped half that food after twenty
day yeah and I'm right our journey here
is ended so thank you very much taking
my extra steps yeah that's right eleven
at least let's do twelve norm yeah